hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem 9 mio leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut wir haben heute noch ein
bisschen länger zeit vor das nächste wie
vermischt product auszupacken als
letztes hatten wir die playstation 4
davor hatten wir dass das iphone oder
hatte man doch ich glaube schon und ich
habe vor einiger zeit auch apple
airports mit lade koffer drake brief
erwischt steht da ich wollte das schon
viel eher machen das produkt gab es
allerdings sehr lange nicht auf mich und
wir haben auch eine schlechte nachricht
und zwar ich hatte ja mal so bush hat so
ein bisschen mit mir zusammengearbeitet
ich konnte man halt umsonst alles
bestellen gut nicht immer aber meistens
und ja die haben mich jetzt subtiles
hatten gekündigt weil ich habe mich da
wohl nicht an die partner program
richtlinien gehalten oder so liegt
natürlich auch daran ich habe auch
gesagt dass manche sachen absolute rotze
sind und ja das kann ich mir auch nicht
nehmen lassen das zu sagen wenn es halt
so ist das würde ich lügen
deswegen ist es jetzt leider erstmal so
aber ist ja gar nicht schlimm wir machen
natürlich trotzdem weiter ich habe es
jetzt gerade nochmal gesagt hast ja ganz
gut hier ein
ich würde sagen wir sind jetzt irgendwo
hier ist das produkt das liegt mir schon
ein bisschen länger rum
ich habe dafür moment aktuell liegt das
produkt bei 96 eur 11 14 eur 21
standardversand ich meine ich habe nicht
über für max ich glaube 82 euro oder
suchen tatsächlich nur dafür bezahlt
sagen einfach mal mit versand um die 95
euro was absolut klar wird also man kann
das vergleichen mit anderen shops oder
sowie verwischt anbietern darlegen die
immer so bei mindestens 110 euro
deswegen das ist schon mal ganz neues
ich bin wirklich gespannt auf ihr hier
jetzt ein originales produkt haben ich
gehe davon aus aber dann wissen kann man
es natürlich nicht ich muss sagen ich
hab natürlich sah mal reingeguckt und
das zuzuordnen muss ich immer machen ne
wir haben auch schon sieht auf den
ersten blick auf jeden fall nicht
schlecht aus mir fällt keine ein bevor
jetzt alle die kommentare was ist mit
der ps4 ich bin euch jetzt den gewinner
kommentar ein suche ich raus ist jetzt
hier einfach eingeblendet
du hast hier gewonnen herzlichen
glückwunsch und ich werde dir zukommen
lassen steht wenn wir noch schönen
abstellungen ich hoffe du freust dich an
klar kommen bei gps fünf raus aber ist
ja besser als nichts jetzt geht es aber
hier um noch mal ganz kurz wie gesagt
ich habe ungefähr 95 und bezahlt dass
dinge hat 3,5 sterne was gar nicht mal
so gut ist wieso dann nicht originalware
sehr praktisch und modernen heutzutage
die kopfhörer sind einfach super alles
tipptopp funktioniert einwandfrei
schnelle lieferung legend airports in
great condition
[Musik]
das ist ein replikat wenn du keine
originalen airports möchtest dann kaufte
es ich habe einen fake produkt erhalten
vertraut diesem angebot nicht ufa kalter
die kopfhörer wurden wir als original me
vergisst man es verkauft erhalten habe
ich allerdings neue manchmal ganz kurz
das ist ich muss sagen was wir machen
können ich suche malkurs ich habe ja
auch airports die originalverpackung von
denen haus daran kann man das ja
vielleicht schon so ein bisschen festen
und später natürlich auch vom sound
wartet das hier sind meine apple
airports der zweiten generation diese
hier sind ja auch zweite generation also
der einzige unterschied der mir auffällt
ist diese seite hier da stehen ein
bisschen andere sachen drauf und das
sieht halt ein bisschen anders aus aber
das war's auch schon
oder habe ich da jetzt wirklich so viel
geld in den wind geschossen wir schauen
mal kurz diese airports featuren weines
connection und hohe qualität audio
blablabla die in der beschreibung stets
nochmal apple airports mit wireless
charging kadri verwischt besser geht es
ja eigentlich nicht also wenn das jetzt
ich könnte originalen sind sicher dass
das ja voll krass illegal weil wenn man
da so viel ware verkauft und darfst du
nicht airports in titel schreiben oder
so die wurden hier an der seite einfach
nur so zugeklebt ist okay wir machen die
mal auf also bis jetzt wirkt alles auf
mich so als wären das originale dinge
hier steht drauf designed by apple in
california wobei ich auch schon oftmals
bei fakes so eine krasse verpackung
hatte dass das hier auch dabei war
wir gehen jetzt hier mal in die
beschreibung die ist natürlich auch
dabei sagt er kurz
also das ist alles schon sehr gut und
für mich auf jeden fall
originell ok eine krasse sache die mir
direkt aufgefallen ist hier steht ja
airports zweite generation bei der
zweiten generation hatte man dann hier
das led lämpchen weil der ersten
genannte also bei meinem so ist es auch
halt davor bei der ersten generation
waren es noch hier drin
genauso wie bei denen das heißt wir
haben hier keine airports der zweiten
generation sondern airports der ersten
generation und wenn man mal auf amazon
schaut findet man die airports der
zweiten generation dort 470 euro und die
der ersten generation schon für 115 euro
das heißt wir haben hier eigentlich gar
keinen krassen preis mehr so also ich
würde auf jeden fall schon mal ein
bisschen durch den kakao gezogen aber
schauen wir mal ob das denn wenigstens
originale sind weil sonst wäre es ja die
die heftigste abzocke also sieht halt
alles wirklich sehr gut aus
wir haben wir einleiten kabel dabei okay
das ist für mich auf jeden fall aus
genau ich glaube das ist auf jeden fall
neues kabel hier an dem airport case
haben wir schon so ein paar kratzer
kleine kratzer dran wenn man das mal so
ins licht hält also die wurden auf jeden
fall schon mal ausgiebig genutzt gut
dann würde ich sagen ich als eine
experte ich kann das am sound direkte
erkennen ob das original sind oder nicht
oder machen
also wenn die fake sind für 95 euro
das wäre absolut meine schlechteste
erfahrung mit ok ich habe mich schon
verbunden die heißen auf jeden fall
erfolgsnachricht ankündigen
siri können ok ok dieses ding dingen kam
auch das klingt schon mal ganz gut es
war mal ein geiles on jan mit gut bass
okay das ist schon mal gut also der
sound ist sehr sehr nice es sind auf
jeden fall originale ich hätte mich auch
gewundert wenn die fei bringen weil die
seen schon sehr gut aus nur halt nicht
der zweiten generation ich denke einfach
mal dieser shop der das hier verkauft
die werden wahrscheinlich einfach immer
das haus schicken was sie gerade da ist
und vielleicht kommen dann wirklich bei
manchen kunden keine originalen an ich
weiß es nicht alte auf jeden fall ist es
ein bisschen dubios ich würde euch nicht
unbedingt raten die dinger zu bestellen
trotzdem mache ich jetzt auch wie bei
den anderen befördert sachen ihr könnt
und coolen kommentar schreiben schreibt
euren instagram damit zu und bei dem
nächsten refurbished product unboxing
könnt gerne ideen in die kommentare
schreiben was ich da machen soll werde
ich dann den gewinner kommentar ein
wenig ihr müsst kein abonnent seien
dafür oder sowas trotzdem freue ich mich
natürlich wenn ihr abonnent seit und
abonniert auf jeden fall also vielleicht
den kanal wanderungen werden heißt wir
sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr wieder gibt
es neues video das war es von mir das
gefallen
haut rein